hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to as most
of you know when you become a critic you
drink this magic juice that immediately
makes you smarter than everyone else
once this liquid is consumed you
suddenly become a member of the critic
League meaning your opinion matters 90%
more than that of the common riffraff
your senses are heightened your brain
becomes bigger and you miraculously know
what's best for everyone in the world
this is the promise of the Tree of Life
all right as many of you probably figure
it out that's not how things work out
for me to say I know but the idea of
critics is kind of a strange one it's so
often that we compare our thoughts to
the critics and probably more than once
you've disagreed with them you either
like something they hate it or hate it
something they liked this usually forces
people to fall into one of two
categories someone that says screw the
critics they don't speak for the people
are a bunch of stuck-up eggheads or the
people that say screw the masses they
would have no art of the Monalisa kicked
him in the balls but what you might be
surprised at is films that are
considered classics today we're not
always seen as such by critics when they
first came out did you know that psycho
The Shining & Fight Club all got
negative reviews when they first
premiered these are movies people watch
all the time they're practically
considered masterworks give very few
critics like them when they came to
theaters the bat said did you also know
that signs Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
and Phantom Menace all got positive
reviews when they first came out good
lord how cute trust anyone with these
kinds of mindsets part of what people
forget though is that critics are just
people and like anyone they can be
emotionally swayed help that's what
movies are supposed to do emotionally
sway you
but how can audiences and critics differ
so much well it's a few things to keep
in mind one is as a viewer you can
choose which movies you want to see so
if something looks bad
you can easily skip over it critics
usually can't they have to sit through a
shit ton of movies including the bad
ones and usually have to see ten times
the amount that normal people see seeing
so many so often can easily have an
effect
and how you view them you notice more
cliches you pick up and where the story
is going to go mostly because you've
just seen it done over and over and over
let her go let her go let her go let her
go movies can get away with a lot of
repeating though because they want to
impress the mass majority not the
critics
so films can use the same tropes several
times because they'll take a mass
audience longer to catch on to it and
get bored by it because well they don't
see movies as much as critics do I
should've killed you when I had the
chance what I had the chance but it
kills you when I had the chance with
that said because critics see movies so
much they might be able to pick up on
certain techniques that are impressive
to them but not the usual movie goer
Birdman was a hit with critics for
different reasons than it might be with
audiences the film is set up to look
like one continuous shot which many
audiences wouldn't catch on to a critic
might be marveling at all the effort
that had to go into making it look like
it was one shot with no edits where an
everyday viewer might just notice that
things look and flow a little different
than usual even if they don't know why
in both cases it worked to the film's
advantage as it was so strange and
dreamlike that audiences and critics
both loved it in some respects that's
true for the Phantom Menace as well it's
a bad film especially when compared to
its predecessors but critics liked it
when it first came out because they
thought the technology and visuals were
breathtaking and at the time I gotta
work now we can see the computers are
overused but back then we never saw a
film that just surrounded itself in so
much of that technology at least not to
this extent and given all the same
things that critics had to see over and
over yeah this would be a little
refreshing but many people were upset
that they couldn't connect with the
story or characters at least they
eventually said that many people were so
sucked in by the hype that for a long
time they convinced themselves that they
liked it even though later they come
around to admitting that they really
don't critics can be the same way
audiences forget that because critics
are people they as well can be emotional
and they can get sucked into the hype
train as well so the idea that critics
are always going to be right doesn't
make the most logical sense oh wait a
minute isn't that one of the reasons we
have critics to see past all the emotion
and focus on the stuff that's going to
be timeless
yessuh no movies are all about giving
you an emotional experience and that's
going to be different for everybody
especially overtime films like Forrest
Gump American Beauty and Saving Private
Ryan we're seeing as hartfeld
powerhouses but nowadays they might be
seen as corny cliched and even kind of
inappropriate each film though touched
on something that was relevant at the
time it made a connection with the mass
public in a way people's emotions wanted
to experience them then this includes
critics mindset at that time period as
well but there are films that everyone
can agree just aren't for critics movies
like Ace Ventura Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles and Fear and Loathing in Las
Vegas we're all panned by critics it's
pretty obvious they weren't made to be
liked by them Ace Ventura worked on an
immature level that spoke to the inner
silliness of most kids Ninja Turtles was
great for fans of the cartoon but it's
just too damn ridiculous to grab someone
looking to be challenged and Fear and
Loathing in Las Vegas by design is meant
to not be light and keep you in a
raunchy and uncomfortable place these
films hit their specific audiences
perfectly where any other rational human
being with little context would see them
as insane ravings if anything we be more
concerned if critics did like these
movies but that makes it even stranger
slash kind of enjoyable when they like
something you wouldn't think they would
like did you know that beavis and
butt-head do America actually got good
reviews in fact it came out the same
weekend as a drama called ghosts of
Mississippi which i canta CAC ters
involved but critics said it was
melodramatic and trying too hard to be
an Oscar Graham meaning that the movie
usually loved by critics was being
beaten out by the one usually despised
by critics it was so weird to see this
dramatic true story about race being
beaten out by beavis and butt-head to
America I was taken with their
adolescent awkwardness bravado and
vulnerability therefore modest
recommendation of beavis and butt-head
do America for me I recommend the two I
enjoyed it a lot but that's not the only
one
films like there's something about Mary
the masks and even the most obvious
commercial with the lego movie all got
good reviews these are films many
guess critics wouldnt like for being too
lowbrow but something extended beyond
the normal boring rubble and connected
with their inner immaturity they were
just too charming and in their own way
too smart to turn down but even I is a
critic have to acknowledge that there's
a lot of enjoyable films with their
reviews that I just don't understand why
was hook hated by critics
I can understand it having problems and
not fully enjoying it but this movie was
slammed commies like UHF seem harmless
enough but the critics railroaded it
like nobody's business we are now even
asked if he ran over all the critics
dogs he couldn't believe the harshness
they can even seem inconsistent like
critics really enjoyed the first rush
hour film but hated the sequels cuz they
said Chris Tucker was too loud and
talked too much did you see the first
film and don't get me wrong I can
totally understand not liking these
movies but claiming the others are doing
something that the first one wasn't when
it so clearly was this is just confusing
and then there's ones youths where
they're picking on just because they
feel they're supposed to as critics I
know tons of people that watch the Hotel
Transylvania movies every Halloween but
because it's an Adam Sandler comedy with
immature humor it's almost like they
feel obligated that they have to give it
a negative review even if it's totally
fine a slapstick comedy starring a
little kid well gotta hate that on
arrival oh it's a Christmas classic no
well um you are all brainwashed
rightfully so nobody controls your
opinions but yourself but if that's the
case why do we even have critics do they
even have a purpose couldn't we just get
rid of them all not so fast destructive
hand of God I have a point critics in
many respects are not only supposed to
cover an event I mean they are
journalism films can be event but
they're supposed to offer a point of
view that you never considered before
would you get angry at someone for
writing a philosophy on life even if
it's different from yours it's not just
something you're supposed to blindly
agree with but it's something that's
supposed to give you a peace of mind
movies are essentially art a reflection
of life and unique and entertaining ways
a critic is supposed to help you explore
it in a way that
you haven't before someone can watch
Animal Farm and like it fine just seeing
it as a story about a bunch of animals
they have rise up against their human
owners but when you're told the whole
story is symbolic of Russian communism
and the rise of Stalin you can suddenly
experience it from a completely
different level and enjoy it in a whole
new way critics are also not just one
big entity it's like saying the Internet
is one person hell if it was it'd be one
emotionally drunk asshole it's a lot of
people with a lot of opinions and while
many of them do follow certain patterns
for the reasons I listed earlier
everybody is different it's all
subjective so nobody can really be wrong
if you like Ace Ventura
go ahead and like it if you hate Saving
Private Ryan go ahead and hate it the
important thing is how will you share
and communicate that's what makes you a
stronger human being and that's what a
good critic should do teach you how to
communicate better not agree but convey
there's been plenty of times that
disagree with critics audiences or both
I sure don't understand why everybody
likes the live-action jungle book but I
also really enjoy the movie Ender's Game
just by that being aided by everybody
my thoughts are going to be different
from your thoughts and chances are it's
gonna happen a lot but that's good share
your thoughts compare them don't let
anyone say there's a right way or wrong
way to enjoy something because there is
no right way or wrong way this is one of
the reasons film is lasted for so long
because it speaks to everybody
differently it's not science it's not
mathematics it always has been what you
allow it to be so figure out what speaks
to you why it speaks to you and best of
all how you can share with others who
might have a similar or completely
different experience
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to
hey everybody next week is a review of
the comic book classic blade but you can
see it now under vessels ad free early
access just three dollars a month to see
tons of people's videos early as well as
a bunch of other extra features check it
out and get the early scoop
hello Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out I think a lot of you know this
charity but if you don't you're about to
see some very awesome people this is the
World Wildlife Fund for 50 years they've
been protecting the future of nature
being the world's leading conservation
organization they work in a hundred
countries and are supported by 1.2
million members in the United States and
close to 5 million globally their unique
way of working combines global wreaths
with a foundation in science involving
action at every level from local to
global and ensures the delivery of
innovative solutions that meet the needs
of both people and nature from for is to
oceans to wildlife to food to freshwater
to climate there isn't anything they
don't try to protect take a look at
their site or their YouTube channel and
see all you can do to keep their cause
strong
you